For digital health data
to help coordinate care,
in our highly specialized and
fragmented system, it must be shared.
To support population health management,
public health, and
research, it must be aggregated for
analysis.
Whenever it is moving, there
are inevitable concerns about respecting
the patient's privacy preferences,
securing it from unauthorized
disclosure, and knowing that
the persons or entities who send it and
with whom it is being shared,
are who they claimed to be.
In this lesson, we've gained a basic
understanding of the technologies and
policies required to achieve all
three of these important objectives.
We've not yet dealt with a question
that is increasingly being asked.
Have we gone too far with this?
Are the complexities we've created
in the interest of privacy security,
and trust now standing in the way
of other important objectives?
For that we talk with Don Detmer,
one of the best known people in
health informatics, and a member of
the committee that wrote the landmark
IOM report, we discussed in lesson one.